a woman who lost everything and as she's
working hard to heal
it was a fire Las Vegas will never
forget we gotta go 10 buildings and two
dozen cars destroyed by billowing Flames
the fire was just so high it was so big
for Diana Silva it was the night her
life changed forever those Embers were
coming at a speed that you just felt the
heat get stronger Silva was sound asleep
when the blaze started at the urban
Lofts on June 19th she escaped with just
her two dogs and the clothes on her back
it's really hard to not replay it what
you could have done Shoulda Coulda
woulda's now nearly two months later
Diana says rebuilding her life has been
anything but easy there is a lot of
maneuvering while you're adapting to
everything else that you need to adapt
to she had serious smoke inhalation and
burned her bare feet but Silva says the
traumatic experience has been especially
hard on her mental health there's times
where I just want to
stay in bed but I can't still she does
her best to take things day by day and
focus on the future what I had no longer
exists and it's not coming back while
also trying to remember what was I left
my identity everything that shaped me
Sasha Loftus live local now